hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream where you never know exactly how
the tech is going to behave until you
actually fire up the live stream
it is live stream number 85 am i correct
about that dr hying that is right
i am dr brett weinstein and uh we are in
an unusual spot as most of our
viewers and listeners will know so i'm
going to ask all of your indulgence
i want to talk about our predicament and
what it is that we're going to do about
it
before we start the show in the normal
sense
many of you will know that i was in
austin this week i went
to do what may be the first in history
emergency
podcast with joe rogan who put me and dr
pierre corey
on to discuss uh the situation of
youtube google censorship and repurposed
drugs it's an excellent piece it's
gotten a very
positive reaction i strongly recommend
you look it up i also
went on lex friedman's wonderful show
and i must say lex and i had never
met before but lex is a marvelous
fascinating and very
unusual human being i really thoroughly
enjoyed
meeting him and i hope that there are
many more discussions to come
but i want to point your attention to
one thing in particular
in my discussion with lex and as
on this show i don't think lex really
does interviews he does discussions with
people but les
alex is so fascinating that obviously
uh they're all pure conversations
he asked me a question that caught me
off guard but it put something together
that i hadn't realized before
lex asked me if i was aware that
martyrdom was a kind of drug that people
could get addicted to
and it was clear that he wanted to know
whether or not
that was in some way motivating us
to challenge power as held at google
youtube and
it immediately struck me that this must
be something that people are thinking
now i don't think there is anything
to this idea but as i said to lex
we are all mysteries to ourselves and it
is always possible that there is
something happening
outside the view of our conscious mind
that is driving that we are unaware of
but in this case i believe something
else is true and i want to tell you a
little bit the question was so good that
i couldn't
help but keep thinking about it on the
plane home and in the days since
and i've come to a conclusion about what
role
this analysis is playing and what the
analysis that i think is correct
might be so
there's a big difference to me and i
would argue inherently
to between people who seek
martyrdom and people who are willing to
risk
things in the pursuit of important
goals these may superficially look alike
but they're
two opposite things it's a little bit
like fission and fusion power
which you can say are both nuclear power
but really they are literally
opposite processes the desire for
martyrdom is in my opinion a selfish
process it is comes out of a need
in in the person whereas the willingness
to take
risks in order to achieve something is
more or less the opposite
it is in some sense selfless now i don't
want to say
that we or i are selfless obviously
human beings are complicated and we all
get something out of what we do or we
wouldn't do it but
in terms of what is driving us i believe
something
that is not entirely visible is playing
out
in order to see it i need to point us to
a discussion an ongoing discussion that
has been taking place largely between me
and jordan peterson
over the course of many years now or
several years at least
and it has to do with the meaning of
myth i think jordan
and i both believe that myth is evolved
and very important in other words it's
it's an adaptation
and therefore has to be treated very
seriously and we dispense with it at our
peril
my point to jordan has been that because
all of our myths evolved in a world we
no longer live in we have to look at
them
with a certain amount of circumspection
we have to reevaluate them because they
may or may not be applicable
to our current situation and i think
jordan
takes them to be likely to be much more
important as they were presented
now leave that conversation where it is
i want to revisit
a number of myths really two of them in
particular that i think are relevant to
our current situation
one of them is the myth of david and
goliath and the other is the allegory of
the cave now the allegory of the cave is
presented as a myth it's not presented
as a modern story or as a literal story
and these in some sense are opposing
myths david kills goliath
the person who leaves the cave in
plato's allegory
is killed by those who don't want to
understand that the real world is
outside the cave and is not contained in
the shadows on the wall
so we should take that in some sense as
a tension we are trying not to find
ourselves in the position
that plato describes and we are trying
to find ourself in david's role but in
order to understand how
this myth emerged and what it means to
us i think we actually have to look
at the story of david and goliath and
see what it is
now if you dig into this you will
discover that historians actually
believe that goliath was a real person
and we'll return to him in a second
david was also a real person but david
did not kill goliath apparently goliath
was actually killed by a person named el
hanan
the story was then subsumed into david's
story effectively by the authors
of biblical texts and the evolutionary
process that followed
from their original authorship in effect
it's like a screenwriter compositing
multiple characters into one
to simplify a story so that it can fit
into two hours of a movie
so elohim fights goliath and wins and
what are we to take from this
well the other part of the david goliath
story the part that does not involve el
hanan and david
involves goliath himself who in all
probability was a real giant
and what does it mean to be a real giant
well those of us who have looked at
the guinness book of world records and
the book of lists and
seen other such discussions know that
every so often nature produces
a very large person now what is
typically going on in the case of these
very large people is that they have a
pituitary tumor
that pituitary tumor does not shut down
the production of
growth hormone at the point that it
should and so the person continues
growing beyond
the normal point of growth cessation
now that has a number of impacts those
of you who have been following
darkhorse who have listened in on the
portal
will be aware that if you are
accelerating growth past the normal
point of cessation
that you will be borrowing from the
capacity of repair and maintenance
and that means that giants may be very
powerful but they are also
fragile and that is in all probability
the deepest message of the david and
goliath story or
better the el hanan and goliath story
so what does this have to do with lex
friedman's question
it has to do this i am not interested
in martyrdom as i told lex
i'm enjoying what we are doing and i
feel that it is far
too important to have it come to an end
by fighting an unfightable
foe i know i speak for you as well in
this regard
either you don't have a desire to die on
that hill
but what people don't necessarily
realize is that dying on that hill is
not the only option
there is dying on that hill we have no
desire for it there is also taking that
hill
and we do have a desire to do that why
in this case
because that hill has to be taken what
google and youtube are doing
is they are infantilizing a huge
fraction
of the population they are making
certain discussions
off limits we are only able to discuss
the covid situation
if we adhere to certain predigested
conclusions and we pretend
that they emerge from evidence which
they do not
the evidence is conflicting and
self-contradictory
what that demands is an analysis that we
are literally not allowed to do on
youtube at this moment
we have to end youtube's hegemony either
youtube has to relent and it has to
allow that conversation
or we have to recognize that youtube is
effectively
like sesame street now where it's going
to tell us things
that it believes to be in our interest
and expect us to just simply take them
in and not
question them that is obviously an
untenable situation
darkhorse is not a program for children
this is a program for adults who are
interested in nuance
it cannot exist on a platform like
youtube if youtube is going to exert
pressure of this form we have to take
this hill
now i do not believe that dark horse
alone can fight google that's very
unlikely
but i would point out to the extent that
the myth of elena
and goliath which becomes the myth of
david and goliath
emerged from an actual historical story
the population of planet earth when that
story took place was less than one
percent the population that
we have now goliath is not likely to be
a person david or elgin is not likely to
be a person
either these are liable to be
conglomerations
google is playing the role of goliath
that is what it has chosen to do
i hope that it is free enough to
unchoose that but we'll find out
david is not going to be a person david
is going to emerge people who are
courageous enough and see the picture
clearly enough are going to join
together and they are going to fight
this battle some of you may have seen
bill maher
last night on his program discussing the
predicament of our channel
it is well worth considering how david
or el hanon is going to form as a matter
of emergence and figuring out how one
can participate in that
for our part we are going to have to
escape
this infantilizing discussion
of crucial life and death medical issues
that we are seeing unfold on youtube and
on the other major platforms
they have effectively created the truman
foe medical show
and it is intolerable it's going to kill
many many people if we are not careful
what can we do well the sword of
damocles continues to hang
over the dark horse you can see our
installation here to demonstrate
that jeopardy and what we are going to
have you do
is we are going to have you move over to
our
new home on odyssey and i want you to
realize that this is
both a practical matter this is a place
that we can continue to broadcast no
matter what youtube
google does but it is also symbolic
the reason that platforms like google
and youtube continue to exist even
though people find the censorship they
are exerting
intolerable has to do with something
called network effects
network effects mean that once you've
got the audience
people have a very hard time figuring
out how to leave of course you can leave
and you can go broadcast somewhere else
but if the audience isn't there what's
the point
so what we're going to do is we are
going to move our audience
to odyssey we are not giving up our spot
on youtube and hopefully youtube will
realize the
gigantic error that it is making and it
will realize that actually
dark horse is meant something as a
warning
right the podcast is named dark horse
because the dark horse
is an entity that is mysterious one does
not know how to bet on it how would you
bet
in a fight between people like us and
google youtube
well simplest thing to do is just to bet
against us because
of course google is huge and we are not
on the other hand the story of el hanan
and goliath tells you something else
it tells you that goliath though
incredibly powerful
is not invulnerable that is what elhenon
figured out was that this giant was
fragile
and that there was a way to attack him
now i believe if you've followed the
story so far
you will understand that because the new
goliath
is an emergent property it is evolved
and that tells us something about its
vulnerabilities
it tells us it will be ferociously
powerful on territory that it
understands well
and it will be a bit dim on territory
it's never seen before
that's the nature of evolved creatures
humans being the lone
exception to this pattern creatures do
not deal with novelty well
goliath does not deal with novelty well
and that is what goliath is now
scratching his head over what the hell
is happening in his attempt to shut down
this discussion
from darkhorse and elsewhere and google
is going to find out
so with that let me ask you if you are
not already watching this on odyssey
to find the link in the youtube
description that will tell you how to
get to our odyssey page and move there
now
and we will start the podcast as normal
all right